hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast principles and
performance characteristics of automated
platelet counting methods presented by
donald wright scientific affairs manager
u.s hematology abbott diagnostics
i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth and
sponsored by abbott diagnostics
now let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer or
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
donald wright
donald wright is a global scientific
affairs manager for abbott diagnostics
hematology
donald has worked in clinical laboratory
services and the commercial hematology
industry for the entirety of his career
he has served in a variety of roles
including automated hematology
supervisor educational coordinator
scientific marketing scientific liaison
flow cytometry and cellular analysis
specialist and several managerial
positions
his research and publications include
applications of monoclonal antibodies
with flow cytometry
characterization of new hematology
product performance and development of
novel hematology assays and markers
in his current role donald provides
scientific support for healthcare
professionals and serves as a scientific
resource to various functions including
r d
business development global strategic
operations and other departments
donald is a member of several
organizations including american
association of clinical chemists
international society for laboratory
hematologists and the american society
of clinical pathologists
for a complete biography on donald
please click on this photo in the top
left corner of your screen
welcome donald you may now begin your
presentation
hello today we're going to start a
presentation
on principles and performance
characteristics of automated plate
accounting methods
this is a web series affiliated with lab
roots
disclosure statement
the speaker program is sponsored by and
on behalf of abba diagnostics
the content of this presentation is
consistent with all applicable fda
requirements
today's hematology analyzer analyzers
utilize various methods for enumerating
platelets including
electrical impedance
light scatter fluorescence
and immunological recognition with
monoclonal antibodies
while these approaches generally produce
an accurate plethod count the majority
of samples
we all know circulating abnormalities
have been shown to negatively affect the
reliability of reported results
impact and quality varies depending on
the specific interference
and technology used to determine the
platelet count
so today in this webinar different
principles used for counting platelets
and the effect of circulating
interferences on the performance of each
method will be reviewed
max schultz and julius
visa zero have been recognized as the
first two to describe clay bits
and their association with hemostasis
schultz described the morphology of
platelets and know that they were
several times smaller than red cells
these are zero further observed
platelets freely circulating the blood
however when subject to an influence
that leads to thrombosis
they adhere to one another to form an
accumulation and stick to each other
so platelets or thrombocytes are a
nuclear discoid cell formed by the
cytoplasmic fragmentation
of non-narrow megakaryocytes
megakaryocytes are the end maturational
stage of seek for the sequence which
starts
with a differentiation of a
pluripotential stem cell
this process is mediated by stimulation
principally by the glycoprotein hormones
gumbo fleet and rtto
the pluripotential cells differentiate
to become morphologically and
immunologically distinct cells commit to
platelet lineage
these maturational changes include
respectively the megakaryablast
promegakaryocyte the megakaryocyte
you can see on the slide
once the cells reach
megakaryoblasts actually loses
proliferative capacity and starts its
maturation process
megacarrier police is this unique way of
maturation it does not occur any other
cell lineage
the cell multiplies its nuclear material
within the same cell which is called
endomytosis
or in other words nuclear division
without cell division
depending on the physiological need of
new platelets
and the mitosis stops the formation of
platelets begin
through a process of cytoplasmic butting
each megakaryocyte is able to generate
between two thousand
and five thousand platelets
which then circulate in the peripheral
blood for about five to ten days or
become cooled in the spleen
platelets themselves play a key role in
primary hemostasis
the initial stage involves platelet
adhesion
in this process the platelets come into
contact with the negatively charged
surfaces of the exposed endothelial of
the damaged tissue
and adhere to them as you can see in the
diagram
this process is principally mediated
through interaction between the plate of
surface glycoproteins particularly
gp1b
formula brands factor and collagen
fibers of the sub endothelial
once platelets have become stuck to the
collagen
they undergo a series of morphological
and biochemical changes which constitute
a secondary phase known as platelet
activation
mediated through cleverage of membrane
phospholipids biochemical signals begin
a sequence of changes
during which intracellular calcium
levels rise
the glycoprotein 2b 3a complex is
expressed in the surface of the platelet
and then these biochemical changes are
associated with distinct morphological
changes
rather than remaining discoid
the activated platelets become more
spherical with a distinct irregular
pseudopod being projected from their
surface
and once activated the platelets begin
to form a template in which the blood
coagulation process is satellite
this
process of platelet activation also
initiates release of secretion of power
powerful secondary aggregating agents
from the plated granules
the release of platelet agonists like
adp and others
causes propagation of the process
which is platelet aggregation as we can
see
on the bottom diagram
during activation exposed glycoprotein
2b and the 3 3a complex on the extended
pseudopods caused by this to bind
together
and basically to form the fibrin clot
the platelet count has become an
accepted part of the automated blood
count
the clinical value of platelet counting
is a critical aspect of patient
diagnosis
and treatment monitoring
and demonstrating of normal platelet
counts and subjects tested part of a
wellness check
are valued and important as part of a
pre-surgical screening process
reported references reference ranges for
the pledge account of normal subjects
typically fall
in the 150 to 400 000 range
uh demonstration of throttle
thrombocytopenia
or
thrombocytosis or valuable if not
specific findings in the context of
disease diagnosis
so when are played accounts performed as
previously mentioned
screening cbc
done routinely
and again as a general wellness
indicator and also for pre-operative
screening
disease monitoring to determine trend in
patients with abnormal blood accounts
are secondary to
disease process
therapeutic monitoring increases or
decreases in platelet counts are
important
when monitoring patients such on chemo
chemotherapy
or other process monitoring
and of course platelet transfusion
ultimately
assessing the severity of
thrombocytopenia
the risk of severe bleeding
and or the need for phytotransfusion
plato disorders are most commonly
cause of bleeding can be divided in
essentially two categories related to
the platelet number
and or the platelet function
in this table below
you can see under platelet number most
often associated with thrombocytopenia
can be two types
of issues one congenital and one
acquired
in the congenital categories you see
things such as megakaryocytic hypoplasia
thrombocytopenia absent radii
and this got aldridge syndrome which is
a very rare
uh
congenital disease
certainly the acquired
reasons include immunothrombocytopenia
trauma thrombotic thrombocytopenic
purpura eic
infections splenomegaly
thumbnail suppression of infiltration
aplastic anemias
by the function
in general there's glandsman's disease
bernard soyas which is very rare
and storage granule defects
and of course you can have all these
acquired planet functions associated
with medication drugs
uremia milo proliferative disorders
which is really a thrombosite of
thrombocytosis
and those associated with multiple
myeloma
accounting technologies and methods
play the technologies
and methods include the following
manual phase microscopy and smear
estimates
are considered to be direct methods of
playback counting
the impedance play account which is
routinely used in the laboratory
as well as optical plated counting which
can include such things as dual optical
angle light scatter
fluorescence and multi-angle light
scatter
the reference method currently by the
icsh which is the international council
for standards in hematology
utilizes the monoclonal approach using
cd41
and cd61 testing for the gp3
a and gp2b
site located on the playlist
and of course there are single platform
approaches using just the immunoplatix
of cd61
base contrast microscopy
this was the standard reference method
by the icsh for many years
and it involves using a new bower
chamber that you see on the screen
and is a graduated chamber that will be
filled with a sample solution
and when looking through
the microscopic objective you can see
the grid lines
that isn't the new bower
and you'll notice in the very center
there's five distinct regions that we
count platelet
the red cells are lysed with the diluent
and then that chamber is charged
and the
microscopist then counts all five
windows
and then using various calculations we
can determine the absolute flavor count
another method is a qualitative plated
estimate
qualitative plated estimate is often
used when an automated system flags the
plate account
it's been a discontinuation of about 10
years of the unipet product which was
used to help uh assist us in
making a quick dilution
and performing the manual pivot count as
we saw on the previous slide
in lieu of this discontinuation a lot of
players had to reassess
how they do plated estimates and now use
this as their alternate technology for
platelet confirmation
when the automated system fails to
provide account
however at very low levels the
coefficient of variation in is high and
may result in increased discordance with
the
an analyzer result
published by nissan chuck back in
1978 one of the only studies that is in
publication
indicates that the cds can be as high as
50 percent when the level of pledge
account is at 27 000
and 20 to 23 when it's between 65 and
100 thousand unfortunately this is what
a lot of laboratories have to resort to
when there's no longer when there's a
flag automated count presented to them
next is the impedance plate account
compensating was first used as a
semi-automated method and subsequently
used in automated cell counters pretty
much from the middle of the 1970s
forward
principle of impedance counting is a
passage of cells
suspended in a known dilution through a
small detection orifice called the
aperture
genuine use serves as an electrolyte
solution through which a constant
electrical turn is maintained between
the two electrodes
the cells flow through the orifice they
impede the electrical current and
resistance is detected
the detection of discrete resistance
permits counting of the event the
magnitude of that resistant pulse can be
used to estimate the volume of that
event
one of the known limitations of the
impedance counting is the potential for
a phenomenon called recirculation or
eddy current effect
which can cause a false increase in the
cell count
this phenomenon is shown in these
diagrams one on the left
you can see the cells passing through
the one on the right what actually
happens is when the cell is located to
the edge of the orifice of the aperture
can actually recirculate for based on
its flow path go back into the detection
zone and be counted again
this can falsely elevate the platelet
count
and
we have to be very aware of this
various approaches to resolve this
artifact have been applied
some
instrument manufacturers use lateral
flow of reagents sweep already counted
fills away from that detection zone
around that orifice of the aperture
other manufacturers use a plate close to
the orifice which ensures that any cell
recirculation
that takes place will be removed from
that detection zone
these devices are often called after
their inventor in this case at the von
baren's plate
another alternative that you see in the
diagram below
makes use of hydrodynamic focusing
this technique employs a sheath of
fast-moving fluid that guides and
confines the cell suspension
and targets it through the orifice the
aperture
ensuring that during analysis cells are
continuously propelled forward
through and beyond the orifice and
therefore away from the impedance
detection zone
one further advantage of using
hydrodynamic focusing is that it focuses
the cells on the very center of that
forefoot
in this diagram you can see the
resulting impedance histogram
the image located on the far left
is a typical
image of a normal plated count
the one in the middle
you can see
by the
line on the right hand side which is
considered the upper threshold of where
platelets should end and rbc should
begin
an overlap region
most likely in this case
due to macrocytic thrombocyte
the one on the far right actually
shows or indicates maybe a mixed
population
of some red cell
fragments or perhaps some
large privates
in any case
the two on the right indicate that we
have a problem with the flight account
and most likely the result will be
flagged and will have to be reconfirmed
by alternate technology
the next mess i'd like to discuss is the
optical plated count
optical methods work on the principle
that diluted sample suspensions pass
through a flow cell optically clear flow
cell
and eliminated by a light source in many
cases a laser light source
scatter from a laser
usually by measuring two angles
simultaneously
is then used to discriminate platelets
from red cells and white blood cells
the advantage of the two-dimensional
approach is that the resolution between
the platelets and non-platelets is not
based on size alone
therefore considered to be more specific
on the right hand side you can see that
there are two different scatter plots
and different angles of of observation
are are made in these two
uh different methods of optical platelet
counting
this is another diagram of optical plate
accounting
in general the low angle scatter signal
represents volume
whereas the higher angle scatter is
derived from the cellular density
in this case
plato's higher angle scatter mainly
represents granulation
the diagram on the left again shows
where the impedance count would indicate
your platelet population
the threshold generally around 33
ventilators
and then your non-platelets that would
be interfering with the count
on the scatter plot to the right you'll
see the optical plate account
is in the center kind of in the gold
population and non-platelets are
indicated by the black population
diagram to the right
you'll see the laser light hitting the
platelets
and here we actually see the light
scatter in really 360 degrees
but the forward light scatter and
wide-angle light scatter where we're
going to detect the difference between
whether it's a platelet or on the right
hand side whether it's a red cell
and again at the platelet side you can
see a higher
volume of light scattered
and also some manufacturers use a dye
that actually stains the platelets that
can be detected at the side angle
scatter area that you can see where
either a red or perhaps a green dye
that's next i'd like to speak about the
reference method
and the reference method
is the most reliable technology for
measuring platelets
as based on the use of monoclonal
antibodies to platelet-specific surface
antigens
the international reference method
employs dual color immunofluorescence
flow cytometry
using a mixture of two different
antibodies pd41
and cd61
platelets are identified by their
reaction with these antibodies you can
see from the center
diagram
and the platelet erector site ratio is
determined by selective gaiting
subsequently erythrocytes are counted in
a separate hematology analyzer
which eventually allows calculation of
the platelet concentration based on the
scatters that we see on the right hand
side
this ics icsh reference method is a
two-platform technique as i mentioned
which involves the use of hematology
analyzer and a flow cycometer
and this cannot be fully automated
this fact and the requirement for an
experienced flow cytometrist kind of
rendered it difficult to perform the
reference method
on a routine basis in the hematology
laboratory
there's another single platform method
available on the market
for immunofluorescent private counting
using the monoclonal antibodies
specifically for cd61
in this approach the antibody is
actually freeze-dried into a small
pellet
and placed into a tube which you can see
in the diagram to the left
packaged in a
certain way the tubes can be taken out
and placed next to a edta tube
and put into a sample rack and process
again in about four and a half to five
minutes you will then have an
immunoplated count
for cd61
here's a clear example of the power of
the immunofluorescent platelet count
in this particular single platform
approach you can see by this diagram you
take a look at the lower right corner
where it says plated o meaning optical
plated eye meaning impedance
and then cd61 under the impedance count
by looking at the platelet o and play
that on you can see that there's
interference looking at the histogram to
the right
the impedance plate account is clearly
overlapping into the rbc song
the optical count as well demonstrates
that there's non-platinum events
located both above and below that uh
orange or gold population
if you take a look at the results
the optical was 43 000 but it has a star
next to it which usually means it's
flagged and has to be
reviewed in this case this device also
does an impedance plate account and in
this case it's 94 000.
the true plate account is actually under
cd61 demonstrated by a two scatter plot
plots below
that has a value of 53 000. so in this
case it played an optical underestimated
account
the npn's overestimated the account
so you can see the value of the emu
plate account distance
so this to summarize
resolving platelet population
one dimension approach
which is impedance
usually shows cells of only the same or
similar size as the separating criteria
the overlap obviously can occur just as
we previously saw on the slide before
two-dimensional approach
involves using two-angle optical light
scatter that we talked about
again you usually can see
clear separation
where there can be instances where again
they could overlap
and again the three-dimensional approach
would be considered the multiple angle
optical light scatter or fluorochrome
tech monoclonal approach
in this case even though there may be
some interferences
or similarities it will ultimately be
separated with the fluorochrome tag
monoclonal antibody
factors affecting plated count
reliability
quality of the plate account may be
susceptible to plated count errors
it's two primary types of error
pre-analytical errors which could be
involved with sample collection
and certainly can involve platelet
clumps
and also analytical errors interferences
that are found based on disease or other
problems such as microsites chistocytes
or giant platelets
outlined in this table below
interferences that impact that account
for liability
falsely increasing your plate account
can be a result of red cell
fragmentation
extreme microacidic red cells such as an
iron deficiency or thalassemia
microangiopathic hemolysis with
schistocytes or two burns with
microspherocytes
wbc fragments can can falsely increase
the planet count
because the fragments themselves are
very difficult to distinguish from
actual platelets even when doing like an
estimate
microsites
bacteria
malarial parasites
protein aggregates
immune complexes and colimicrons can all
contribute to falsely increased platelet
counts
decreases can be included by the clumps
such as edta induced platelet
aggregation
we call that platelet neutrophil
stealatism
or poor sample quality due to clotting
activated platelets through the
degranulated platelets
and of course abnormal platelet size
giant platelets such as in bernard soyer
syndrome main hegemon anomaly mild
dysplasia syndromes central
thrombocytopenia
or microscape platelets as in riscott
aldridge syndrome
rbcs are small enough to be classified
as platelets
in this smear review you can see on the
right hand side very small red cells
right right hand side you can see red
cell schistosites
in both cases this can impact
the pivot counts
those can be generally counted as
platelets by impedance systems and
sometimes can even confuse the optical
athletic count as well
generally speaking when mcb's are less
than 60
the distribution will have some that are
even much smaller than 60 and that's why
they may be counted as large platelets
wbc fragments can be classified as
platelets too and if you take a look at
this smear
around the white blood cells and where
the arrows are pointing you can see
these small
white blood cell fragments
and certainly any acute leukemia or high
grade lymphoma or malignancy treated
with chemotherapy these can be a major
contributor to false increase in
platelet count
before our right hand side acute
megaloblastic leukemia
one of the key reasons we see the
wbc fragments
should always be alert that
overestimation should be suspected in
all cases of malignancy where platelet
count is higher than expected
although rare microorganic
microorganisms may be responsible for
unreliable platelet counts
in this mirror you can see intracellular
platelets or parasites rather
and in that case sometimes as the red
cell were to hemolyze they may become
free
and they falsely impact the platelet
count by increasing it
abnormal proteins may result in an
increased count as well
diseases or factors for abnormal plasma
aggregates as affecting the platelet
count can impact many of the methods
especially the impedance plate account
conditions associated with pair of
proteins are cryoproteins
and or mainly disorders of b cells and
include lymphomas or myelomas and
macroglobulin anemia
say that clumps and aggregates are
common cause of falsely decreased plated
counts
we've previously described
in the
smear review over on the right hand side
you can see platelet bumps
clearly would decrease your platelet
count
and play the satellite doses the right
hand side will also be a candidate for
decreasing your plated count
giant platelets may be misclassified as
rbcs or excluded from the count fairly
they occur primarily in the
myeloproliferative disorders such as the
chronic myeloid leukemia and
thrombocythemias
and in rare hereditary disorders
uh it can also be acquired conditions
such as the autoimmunity of pathogenic
purpura
the microangiopathic hemolytic anemias
places in these conditions are as large
as or even larger than normal red cells
and again in most systems that overlap
between the platelet population and the
red salt population
small platelets that may be excluded
from the platelet count can occur as
well
uh such as with aldrich syndrome you can
see how tiny these are generally
platelets that fall
on the lower threshold of less than two
to three centimeters it may be
inadvertently excluded from the plate
account
so this can be a reason for again a
lower account than expected
so what can be the clinical impact
associated with errors in the plate
account
most important
is associated with the
plate account is when the transfusion
decision
is to be determined whether to give
platelets or not to give platelets
and one of the key provisions here is
the plated count transfusion trigger
level
generally most laboratories and
clinicians will look at a level of about
10 000
and that count becomes very important
because obviously at the very very low
level that it is the interferences that
we previously saw can impact that value
so let's take it for example
if platelets
counts were
less than the 10 000
they would be needed
with regards to platelet transfusion as
given
the limit risk of cerebral bleeding is
is taken care of
but if they're not given certainly the
increase in cerebral bleeding
can occur
if the plate account transfusion trigger
is not needed
may cause unwanted clinical effects such
as a transfusion reaction if they're
given
again because the erroneous platelet
count
being too
low and also the expense and unnecessary
waste of plated products as we know
platelets are very expensive
and
from an inventory standpoint also
expensive to keep on hand
obviously if it's not needed we have a
good count
not given there's no
um no impact on the on the patient care
so limitations of differential pledge
accounting methods associated with
transfusion decisions
the far right hand side you can see i've
labeled suitable for transfusion
decision management
and over on the left hand side the
particular method
manual plate account
again because of its
interferences based on plasma proteins
really do not impact it nor do
interferences from microsites
or interferences rbc or wbc fragments
although sometimes the wbc fragments
even the newborn chamber very hard to
distinguish between platelets
but you can count giant platelets you
can see those clearly
but it does have a very low level of
accuracy as we've previously described
and imprecise at less than ten thousand
so when it comes to suitability or
transfusion decision management i would
consider it highly unreliable
from the impedance plate account method
interferences can occur with plasma
proteins
interferences from microscience
uh rbc wbc fragmentation
and of course the ability to count giant
platelets no because if you recall only
looking at size those would most likely
fall into the red cell window
so it has a low level of accuracy we
would say below 20 000.
it's somewhat reliable
but again we'd recommend reviewing a
smear before any play that transfusion
would be administered
the optical plate account
again uh occasional interferences may be
so from plasma proteins if it's
aggressive aggregates
sometimes interference is from
microsites
and again this can occur if the
schistocyte or the microscientist is
abnormal in such cases with emulated
platelet most likely this will not occur
this is kind of actually rare
interference is from rbc wbc fragment
again occasionally
but again distinguishing the platelets
from the red cells even if they were
in fragmentation form
plate that is usually considered
denser through the granulation
and will separate from these
ability to count giant platelets
again can be variable
so
from a low level of accuracy well it's
limited to about 10 000 or that
transfusion threshold that most most
laboratories would use
more reliable than impedance
but you still would need to review a
smear
and of course the amino plate account as
we reviewed
there's virtually no interferences we've
seen across most of the primary uh
interfering substances
accurate believe it or not down to about
1 000 and certainly is the method of
choice
and is why the icsh considers it the
reference method
so let's summarize
whether counts are particularly
important for clinical decisions on
administering platelet products to
patients with
thrombocytopenia
most methods for platelet counting are
not very precise in the lower range
and their accuracy can be compromised by
the interferences we described
you know analytical limitations of
plenty of county may challenge the lower
planet transfusion threshold of 10 000.
again that's where we have to then make
a determination
if there is access to the immunoblood
account as that being the the the
approved or the best way to make a
decision for legal transfusions
and of course the technological progress
continues to bring improved planet
county methods
at this time i'd like to ask if there
are any questions
and open up the lines
and i do appreciate your time
thank you donald for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the answer question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question is
if impotence method for platelets is so
prone to problems why are so many
vendors still using this technology
oh thanks for that question and uh yes
impedance technology is robust nowadays
i i didn't mean to imply otherwise in a
sense but we must understand that with
impedance technology we do know what
interferes with it
and actually that's a positive because
when we do see the interference we know
we need to
obviously look at an alternate
technology to validate that particular
account
so it's a it's a robust method um
from an economic standpoint i'm sure
it's uh well-known uh and easy to put
into systems
and again as i also described in the
presentation
you know a lot of the newer systems have
resolved many of the types of error that
occurred in the earlier systems with
using impedance
now that that's such as hydrodynamic
focusing
um again
eliminating any kind of recirculation
problem into the detection zone
uh so it didn't mean to imply that it is
a
bad method in any way whatsoever it's
actually like i say quite robust and if
anything
when you have an error you will have an
error and you know that you have an
interference
that is present that that the particular
sampling needs to be resolved so
i hope that helps to clarify that
next question our next
yes we have television in our lab what
do you think of the performance of the
platelet count estimation versus other
methods
well the television and like i would
probably approach all digital morphology
type systems
is um
i think the key
word in your question is plated
estimation
as we know these are not um
devices that have been
necessarily cleared some may have for
that account but it takes a great deal
to
obviously come up with an algorithm
that's extremely accurate as compared to
doing an actual fixed
solution on a whole blood sample
and then counting it in a event by event
a clear distributional advantage
method that gives you an event per event
based on the pollution ratio
so in that sense you know you're you're
you're subject to in all of digital
morphology quality of the smear
and of course if there's any issues with
regards to making that smear that can
also
jeopardize or compromise your your
estimate that you're getting but again
it's an estimate it's based on pure
statistics and numbers of events that
you can actually evaluate
um
i'm sure they do a great job and almost
give you a good estimate of what you're
doing as good as you would be able to do
perhaps maybe better uh as an individual
sitting down microscopically reviewing
the field
but still just the same it's not like
actually getting a good number of a high
number of events when you have
an automated approach to it
so donald our next question is on slide
19 where you mentioned that platelets
and rbcs show unique signatures using
multi-dimensional analysis
can you describe more about what you
mean by the unique signatures
yes
again as we have evolved in counting
and evaluating platelets from automated
methods obviously
as i did in the kind of dimensional
overview of looking at just size it's
been a great uh asset in counting
accuracy and giving us the values that
we can actually use from
a clinical standpoint
but when it comes to again interferences
this is the
the prime objective of almost any
areas from science platelets is to try
to resolve as many of those
interferences we possibly can
so the evolution of optical platelet
analysis did give us what we felt
another dimension to being able to
resolve some of the
problems that occur especially if you
have
two events of the same size and
impedance obviously takes
you know a rather
strong algorithm to try to decipher what
that is and if it is truly an
interference or just part of the
rbc populations
so the difference between platelets and
rbcs obviously there are some physical
characteristics that we can take
advantage of when looking at them
optically or again by other methods as i
suggested but the amino plated account
the primary is this obviously
planets have granules red cells
generally don't they shouldn't
and they have hemoglobin and platelets
don't
so if we can take advantage of some of
those intracellular characteristics and
perhaps we can get another
dimension of of
of being able to define each one of
those signals into two distinct events
so with that being said when we get into
more
additional
approaches
again the definitive is using the
monoclonal antibodies that are sensitive
to the 2b
and 3a sites of glycoproteins in the
platelets that's the that's the ultimate
but again as i mentioned it's it's not
practical to do one of those all the
time so we're we need to look at a
practical approach you know again that
we're evolving of using perhaps more
angles of light together that could give
us
uh or different dyes that could give us
more information be more definitive and
classifying the the red stuff in the
plato you have the interference or and
more importantly
those that may be of the same size
i have heard there is a new tube by
sarstead for pseudothrombocytopenia
do you have any information on this tube
or what can it do for the lab
um
yes i mean i've heard about it i've not
worked with it so all i know is from
this standpoint
we know that there is a
situation where edta sensitivity
uh from
individuals can cause platelet
cellulitosis
around white cells neutrophils in
particular and
when we see that obviously we know we
have a decreased platelet count so
again i i emphasize you know very
important to
make sense out of your results always
cross check look to see what there is
and obviously if there's a decreased
plate account you know you would then
should do a
scan or review of the smear
this particular tube from what i
understand obviously uses the alternate
to the edta
so that would eliminate the sensitivity
to that and supposedly it would
cut down or eliminate supposedly the the
sensitive
edta satellite system and that would be
a good thing
but again you'd have to
probably do a redraw in that case and
then perhaps then
rerun that sample
is there any procedure to avoid platelet
clumps for accurate platelet count
just
as again mentioned in the presentation
this is obviously a pre-analytical issue
most of the time
and it does evolve in bulk rather
you know just taking your
precautions
and following the appropriate technique
for phlebotomy
when you're drawing any type of samples
as we know
sometimes when the sample is not mixed
correctly on
a drawing and other factors that can be
involved with creating the
the clot but pretty much i think if you
follow the appropriate techniques uh in
in phlebotomy we can avoid a lot of
those mixing well after blood has been
drawn
and all the other you know precautions
that you should take
so other than that i am not a
advocate of if there is a
sample that's received in laboratory
when you do see clots
i know some laboratories do try to
remove those quads by
agitation uh or something uh related to
that uh vortexing etc
uh i just think that they create more
problems than you start out with aside
from that perhaps requesting a new
sample i know that's more difficult for
the patient and sometimes the patients
and outpatients it's very hard to get
that sample back in
but i think you know again most
laboratories have a standard operating
procedure
set up to to to manage that
so donald our next question how do you
estimate platelets with a low hematocrit
um
very difficult
and more importantly as you do have to
consider you're doing a plated estimate
that you have your microscopic factors
suggested appropriately for your samples
that have anemia and again
i think if you look at any of the
texts on how to conduct an appropriate
um you know plated estimate the you know
describes and it is painful as a matter
of fact and if you have even two
different
manufacturers of microscopes each one of
those should have different uh
factor involved when when it's uh
regarding how many platelets per field
you should be spotting because obviously
the objectives may be different
so it's just a matter of of making sure
that you've done enough of your
pre-work to assure that your factors are
good
and robust enough and also you've done
in your studies and have documentation
for your factor
analysis that you've done some with
those that have anemia and very little
hematocrits so it's just part of your
setup for doing an accurate plated
estimate
now what is the principle behind cd61
enabled to eliminate platelet clumps
interference
well um
cd61
process will not actually eliminate
platelet faults
if plato clumps are found you're going
to actually probably
in the one single platform i discussed
there'll be actually flags that come up
and still indicate there's plenty of
pump
but what it can do is that if there are
schistocytes or other interferences that
could resemble platelets or other types
of interferences maybe white blood cell
fragmentation
fragments those are very very difficult
to resolve
and certainly the
61 and or 41 reference method
uh would be very specific it is very
specific replay that's in and all other
interferences are eliminated the one
thing it would not eliminate if you had
plated clumps uh it would attach to the
clump and be very bright and it would
probably trigger
would most likely trigger a flag that
you have excess of large platelets in it
and you would still have to repress the
new sample
so donald you stated that immunoplatelet
is unable to count giant platelets why
um
what's that question one more time
please
of course
so uh the question is you stated that
immunoplatelets is unable to count giant
platelets why
that's not true i don't think i said
that
amino plate account can count diet
platelets
the other methods on the market which
could be again some optical again the
impedance
and those are the ones that are more
difficult to count those who will have
some sort of a flag due to overlap
but if again you know any type of
macrocycle thrombocytes present you know
it will have the appropriate lack of
protein sites to adhere to cd61 so that
if that was uh
understood in that manner that i
apologized and perhaps maybe uh
uh just want to correct that but the
amino play that well count giant play
this effectively
more so than any other method on the
market um the other thing too if you'll
recall on the table i also indicated
that you know one one of the interesting
things
certainly your your estimate will help
with giant platelets
as well as doing a manual count which is
very rarely done anymore uh those giant
players can be seen as fault in those
uh but the immunoplay that can
and will effectively count giant
platelets
all right so our next question looks
like what methods exist for detecting
immature platelets
i didn't touch on the image or platelets
so much but the obviously the method
methods on the market today
usually evolves some sort of nucleic
acid dye
and the immature platelet obviously has
residual rna and
with these particular
stains or dyes that are intrinsic within
the reagent systems do stain those and
when you do a plate account in this
manner you're looking for fluorescence
and the amount of fluorescence is
directly proportional to the amount of
rna residual it's in that particular
platelet and from that we can actually
begin to
understand you know the the amount of
immature platelet production that is
present in that particular sample
um
again one of the problems with the
immature reticulocyte farm side the
immature platelet
fraction is there are no standards yet
in the industry there's there's probably
the controls aren't optimized at this
point it's not really an excellent
analog that would cross
all the technologies and methods that
are out there
that exist
so you're you're going to have to abide
by the
manufacturer that you're using currently
as your
source and reference range
approach to how you establish that in
your laboratory
there has been and there is i believe um
ongoing discussions in the icsh
international council
for standardization hematology to
obviously
uh find means and ways to find standards
for such things as the
uh immature platelet fraction as well as
even the immature red cell reticulocyte
fraction
because those are still again more
technology dependent so those are still
challenges that have to be resolved in
the future
donald in your opinion what would be the
next key breakthrough in automatic
platelet counting technology to advance
the field other than more angles of
light scatter
well
i think there's one
approach that obviously has proven
itself to be the most robust and that
would be
the immunoplated count and um
two things of breakthrough would would
have to occur i think there'd have to be
a
reduction in cost of the monoclonal
itself to make it more practical to
reflex whenever you had any type of
flank
associated with a platelet count on an
automated system
it is a reference method so
in hematology
we don't work in the same environment
that chemistry does where you can go in
and pull out a standard
and calibrate a system to a reference
standard and we don't have that
hematology except for one and that would
be the immunoplatelet count so if we
could get the cost down
and have that in a
platform that could obviously deliver
that
in a completely automated fashion i
think that would be one of the the most
exciting steps there is as far as
accuracy goes and could certainly
um i think help the clinician in many
ways knowing that their plate account
they always believe everything's perfect
from the laboratory i kind of laugh at
that but
from a laboratory standpoint we always
know we'd have the absolute best place
account that we could
deliver to the clinician
with regard to platelet transfusions is
there any research underway that you
know you know of to produce artificial
platelets that could be used in a human
transfusion
um what we've looked at and i've worked
with some companies and um there are
the polymeric type of of um artificial
play that that's been worked on for
probably uh i'd say 10 plus years
this doesn't seem to have resolved
uh into a commercial product or evolved
their commercial product at this point
i'm aware of also the approach of taking
platelets
human platelets and in biophilizing them
and packing them so they have extended
shelf life
from a cost standpoint to be used in
remote areas where it's hard to
obviously um
uh transport the product the liquid
product uh you know two remote areas
and a lie authorized product might be
the next step in in the evolution of
platelet transfusion
um
again one of these things
how far away away from a synthetic
product
it's very difficult to you know
many areas of medicine have been trying
to use synthetic products whether it be
rbcs whether it be
um
any type of of joint replacements and
things
they definitely have their drawbacks and
some have not achieved any clinical
success so i think we're a little ways
away yet
but i do see
some of these other products that come
in are coming up in research that may be
good alternatives
we've gotten so many good questions
today but it looks like we only have
time for one more
why are platelet levels so high in
pediatric patients less than a year old
well that's an excellent question and
and uh there's several publications out
there and it's um
uh pretty well known that the obviously
the thromboplatin is the primary
regulator of megakaryo polices in in
the production
and it's pretty well established that
tpo concentrations and
kind of the
non-thrombocytopenic
preterm and term infants is
significantly higher than in healthy
adults
so with that being said it's
it's uh important that your reference
ranges are set appropriately
so clinicians don't overreact or more
importantly they're not looking at adult
ranges
uh which could then make them
have cause to obviously
um
consider other types of
diseases or or can continue to test for
something that may not in fact not be
there
so um with respect to that i think it's
important to again establish your
neonate and pediatric reference ranges
to manufacturers uh
system that you're working with and and
obviously have this posted
you know in the laboratory and making
sure that those are also in your
in your results page whenever those are
reported out
thank you again donald do you have any
final comments for our audience
well again i appreciate you know your
attendance today
and certainly the topic of plato's will
be with us for many years to come and
hopefully we can continue to improve
on the accuracy of these uh these
reports and the the ability to count but
it's
in all diseases and and eventually get
to the point of eliminating
interferences as being a problem with
with counting
you know i have a lot of
hope that we can get to that point i
think we have some methods out there
that could potentially get us there and
certainly i think it's still a very
important topic because obviously
uh we have a
variety of different systems out there
so most importantly is if you question
something always confirm it with the
smear um so a strong believer in human
identification
of uh detection of disease
so again i thank you and i appreciate
your time today
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
or those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of the registration
we would like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor abbott diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through december of 2018.
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
and we're